Ramsay Bolton of "Game of Thrones" was a terrible leader of the North...
...and made numerous errors during the "Battle of the Bastards."
Here are three leadership takeaways from his final episode.
1. Lead by example.
Will your men wanna fight for you when they hear you wouldn't fight for them?
He's good.
In the thick of battle, Ramsay watched while his men fought.
Actions speak louder than words.
You cannot expect employees to do the work...
...that you yourself are not willing to do.
Remember, employees leave managers, not companies.
2. Don't waste resources.
We'll just kill our own men. Stand down!
Loose!
Ramsay had no problem depleting his army quickly in order to win,...
...but in reality, resource allocation is critical to strategy.
Consider the larger picture beyond narrowly focused goals...
...to understand the scope of your financial and human resources,...
...budget low and set aside additional resources to account for any emergencies.
3. Have a backup plan.
Ramsay's inability to plot for the worst inevitably led to his downfall.
My hounds will never harm me.
You haven't fed them in seven days, you said it yourself.
Good leaders anticipate the possibility of failure from the start.
Don't hesitate to change direction,...
...implement Plan B or adjust the pace when an initiative doesn't go as planned.